so have you met have you met anybody
here yet oh no no yes first time yeah
we're all excited were like is he gonna
perform I'm like no he's actually gonna
do something else oh so I'm very excited
about it that's with your son I told you
backstage I think he's adorable
Sebastian six now right here app he does
he's got like his own little playlist of
music like when I come in the car or
when he gets in the car after school
he's like Daddy played this song this
song that song my daughter's bossy like
that - yeah I mean I'll try to put them
on the new stuff he'll try and do that
and I'm like I love I mean I just grew
up on Tupac little baby I love all that
stuff in any time place she's like not
only hear this oh yes
exactly yeah all right so I heard you
also coach bashes is a baseball team I
do coaches baseball teams and I'm just
wondering one who's like when you show
up and you're the coach at all the
parents are like it's crazy because one
of the coaches actually came up to me
and he's a he's a fireman and he just
told me this yesterday he was like I was
watching TV and not seen an interview
with you on there and I was like well
what the heck is the Dodgers coach doing
on TV he didn't even know I was a
rapper's maybe I'm doing such a good job
as a coach it's hard to like one other
finds mean comment sometimes see kids
and also just have the time to do stuff
like that so it's awesome you take the
time yeah yeah for me is super important
I love children and this is the most
important time in his life especially
spending there with me and having his
friends and the relationships that
they're gonna build so any hand that I
could have in that I'm trying to do it
that's well I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this